we have an update for you on a story
we've been following exclusively on CBS
mornings about a 16 year old from
Ukraine trying to come live with his
aunt in the U.S a U.S citizen she's in
California his parents in Ukraine sent
him to meet that on in Poland and we met
her there on the Ukrainian border where
she told us unfortunately the U.S
embassy had refused to Grant the
teenager a Visa well after a long and
often traumatic Journey that teenager is
finally in California arrived in May
Anna Werner has his story
[Music]
this is how Marina safes fight to rescue
her 16 year old nephew finally ended
with a hug
Safi a ukrainian-born U.S citizen had
been working to bring Ilia Prock in to
live with her in the Bay Area since late
February his parents can't leave Odessa
safi's sister is a police officer and
men over 18 aren't allowed to leave so
they put the teenaged Ilia on a train to
the Polish border where Safi flew to
pick him up that's where she learned a
hard truth as she told CBS morning's
Tony decouple when we went to the
American Embassy they just turned us
away at the time the U.S had no program
for Ukrainian refugees fleeing the war
America the country of free people and I
am a free person cannot bring my only
nephew from the war zone
that's the reality how come with no
clear way for Ilia to enter the U.S
Marina says the only other option for
him seemed to be crossing the Mexican
border so I felt like
okay I will try so a month later her
husband Bhajan returned to Poland then
traveled with Ilya through Spain
Colombia and finally to Tijuana Mexico
where Marina met back up with him and
begged U.S border officials for
permission to take him home with her
they refused what was that like it was
horrible I was sad
I was worried and extremely angry
extremely I was angry at at the system
at the system officials then separated
them and sent her nephew first to a
Detention Center then a shelter it was
like a jail and the thought it's a jail
but for kids the 16 year old waited for
weeks not knowing what would come next
you can just do whatever you want with
me because I have no documents I'm not a
human here you felt like you're not
human you weren't human yeah sure I'm a
prisoner it's not clear how many other
Ukrainian refugees both adults and
minors are still seeking entry into the
U.S even though the Biden Administration
launched a fast track program in April
for those fleeing the war some other
Ukrainian miners have been sent to
shelters Melissa Adamson is an attorney
with the national Center for Youth law
separating children from family members
can be extremely traumatic we can have
short and long-term effects for their
health for their mental health it can be
extremely traumatizing she visited the
shelter where Ilya and other Ukrainian
miners were held and just to paint
another picture of the facility for you
it's very small the facility is
surrounded by a metal chain-link fence
all of the doors and the windows inside
have alarms on them there's no green
outdoor space we're gonna make a wish
today but Ilya is now finally free and
safe after his long journey to the
relief of his parents still in war-torn
Odessa his dad said Marina IOU you till
the end of my life I started crying
really it was tough you never think that
he one day he will text you things like
that
saying
how grateful he is for me saving his
son's life and that he will never forget
it do you feel like that's what you did
you saved his life oh absolutely
absolutely
and it's just wonderful to see that
particular family reunited but of course
there are no simple stories in this
country no simple policy decisions
either so while Ilya is safe with his
extended family there in the Bay Area
there has been criticism about the Biden
administration's decision to fast-track
Ukrainian refugees while at the same
time deprioritizing those who wait
sometimes much longer to cross on the
southern border that's right so many
people who are fleeing violence in their
home countries like the ukrainians are
and and what Ilya said paints a very
strong picture of the detention centers
that we've reported on where he says he
felt that he was not human that you
could do whatever you want to him
because he doesn't even exist